first of all uh the
protocol isn't actually even yet being
implemented and it's all it's because
there it's all been put into uh a
cold storage and while we uh try and
manage it were it to be implemented it
would do even more uh damage diverting
trade and
that is upsetting the balance of the
belfast good friday agreement you've got
a problem at the moment which is that in
in northern ireland the
stormont assembly the government of
northern ireland
can't meet because of the effects of the
protocol what it does is it creates
unnecessary barriers on on trade east
west
what we what we can do is fix that it's
not a big deal uh we can fix it in such
a way as to remove those bureaucratic
barriers but without putting up barriers
on trade moving north south in the
island of ireland as well that's what we
want to do and so in terms of the
strategy the overarching objective the
primary thing we got to do is make sure
that we protect the balance of the
belfast
good friday agreement that means
respecting trade east west between gb
and ni but also trade uh north south for
the northern ireland what would you say
to those conservative mps who are
thinking of voting against
this who think that you are potentially
breaking international law and could
spark a trade war i think i think our
higher and uh prior mainly international
obligation is to the belfast good friday
agreement to the peace process in
northern getting that stormont assembly
up and running again every northern
ireland is a is fantastic but it needs
government it needs particularly now uh
when people are facing uh pressures from
the
global cost of living uh problems with
the energy price bikes you need a
government in order you need stormwater
up and running so we've got a plan to
fix it well we'll wait and see on that
i'm not sure the epsilon just two two
other things that i can first of all the
economy yes uh figures are today again
negative growth in april we're facing a
recession aren't we prime minister
the uk came out of the covid pandemic
faster than
other comparable countries because of
the steps that we took that's why we had
the fastest growth in the g7 last year
it's true that other countries are now
catching up and we're seeing the effects
of
inflation around the world hitting this
country as well as everywhere else but
if you look for instance at the the imf
data uh the the uk comes back at or near
the top of the of the g7 league uh very
quickly and the most important thing is
we have the
fundamentals that are very strong we've
got a situation now where we've got the
lowest unemployment since 1974. so the
issue for just this business what i've
been talking to today is incredible uh
courgette
uh
broccoli uh
growing business what they need uh is
that they need people to come and help
them uh pick the the courgettes now that
is so different from the economic crises
i remember when i was uh when i was
younger in the 80s in the 90s millions
of people on the scrap heap because
told they were on the scrap heap because
of mass unemployment that was a total
disaster we're in a different situation
now we've got an inflationary price bump
that we've got to get through we're
shielding people 1200 pounds for the 8
million most vulnerable households and i
think we'll get through it very strongly
indeed maybe not to make a connection
between these two issues but you could
um have some people who are going to
send to rwanda to come and work here
what what is happening it seems that
those figures are collapsing it's
possible that no one's going to be on
the flights
this week so i think it's
i've been very clear that throughout i
think if you go back to the
speech i i gave about what we were
trying to do right at the beginning when
we uh announced the policy i always said
that it would begin with a lot of
teething problems and you would have a
lot of uh legal action against it but
i've and and they would try and delay it
you know that's that's inevitable but
what we're trying to do
is stop the business model of criminal
gangs who are preying on people moving
them across the channel in unsea-worthy
vessels risking their lives and
sometimes costing their lives but it's
worse than that what they're doing is
undermining people's confidence in legal
migration and people's support for legal
migration we have safe and legal routes
for people to come into this country
i've just talked about it for people who
uh to come and
work in agriculture or whatever we have
that you it should not be undermined by
criminal gangs who are risking people's
lives and that's what the ronda policy
is all about